People are definitely gonna be shocked.
We kept this a secret for like 40 weeks.
Me being injured was like
a blessing in disguise.
Those moments and memories were huge
for kind of what helped
blossom our relationship
into what it is.
Are you...?
I hope this continues to kinda show people
that there's no perfect way to find love,
or have a family or create a family.
We're just looking forward
to kind of continuing
to write our story, but with...
...with a baby.
A little one.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Are you nervous?
Yeah!
You better talk more than me.
Why can't I be the best
player and also have a baby?
But not carry a baby.
You know, why can't we do both?
WNBA Champion, Breanna Stewart.
Stewart gets 15 seconds on the clock.
Ball behind the back,
she'll lay it up and in.
Really, are you gonna try
to put a hook shot up on Breanna Stewart?
Just a quick story.
The night she got hurt,
that's the night we started.
I just remember being in such a place
where it was like, you know,
something terrible happened,
and then at the same time
something amazing happened,
and I was like, is it any
way I can go back to Russia
with a torn achilles?
Can I just go there, and then go?
I had this ring made since November.
And it was just about like
finding the right moment.
What's up, guys? This is Devin, Katie Lou.
We're here to witness the
greatest wedding of all time.
Follow us.
When I was younger did I have any idea
that I was going to marry a woman?
I had no idea,
but she's the one I want to be with,
and we are living our best life.
From this day forward,
I promise to be your wife, and partner.
Marta, you may now kiss.
You're married!
Yay!
Cheers!
So, when I decided to freeze my eggs,
I really didn't know why I was doing it.
If I'm gonna be honest,
it was just the fact that I'm injured,
I can't play,
this is the perfect
opportunity, because when else
am I going to get a two-week
period where I'm not playing?
It was probably one of the
best decisions I've made,
really in my life,
because you're setting
yourself up for the future.
I've always felt that I
wanted to start a family
when I was younger, but as
a womens basketball player,
it's like, okay, how do you do that?
How do you plan that perfectly
so the baby comes in the summer?
Now, after the Olympics for 2021,
which well, we're cutting
it a little close.
Amor
Where are we?
Idaho.
What are we doing here?
3D appointment for Ruby.
So exciting!
Her lips.
I know.
I'm like, whoa.
She has botox in there?!
Wow, look at that.
She has such round cheeks.
Now it's 29 weeks.
She looks like a 31 week baby.
Yeah.
Four pounds.
This is her face.
Look at her lips.
Four pounds.
Four pounds,
two weeks ahead of schedule.
We need her to stay in there-
Yes, please.
'til her due date, 'cause of the Olympics.
And now we're going back to Seattle
quick trip.
Today we are going to put
together the stroller,
because Ruby comes in eight weeks
and we need to get it together.
Oh, right here.
Hah!
Come here.
Stew, you don't know what's happening.
Come here, we gotta test it out!
How do we open this thing?
Amor, we cannot teach him this already.
Sit.
Good boy.
Shout out to Sami, Kate and Nash.
They sent us a little
care package of things
that they didn't know that they needed
when Nash was born.
There's a hairbrush.
That she said she's
gonna use it for herself.
Yeah, maybe I'm gonna use it, too.
But I don't brush my hair.
I thought that was for Stew.
What is it?
It's a diaper bag.
Oh.
Probably could use it for Stew, too.
Sorry.
The white noise.
For the shh.
I'm going to shush you.
That's on our baby list.
Oh, and this is the thing
that I said I wanted,
and Marta said,
"I don't know if it's
comfortable for babies."
Nash would only go to sleep
in this when he was a baby.
This was a lifesaver, so
we didn't have to swaddle,
where the babies are
just stuck in that thing.
And we just moved into our condo.
It's messy.
Un poco messy.
But look at the kitchen.
In that one.
She has a fire diaper bag.
This one?
Look at it.
We just needed it.
You know, obviously, I'm not pregnant.
They're like, is Marta pregnant?
Marta can't be 34 weeks
pregnant right now.
So just explaining the whole situation,
about how it's a little different,
how we started it,
how, like using a surrogate.
But I think that's one of the experiences
that makes it kind of cool
for people to see like other sides
of more than just
traditionally having a baby.
She wanted to get this
just in case we go to Cabo.
Oh yeah, we're going to Cabo.
We are going on a vacation.
I don't know where we're going,
but we are going somewhere.
Ruby is thirty...
four weeks.
34 weeks.
The size of a pineapple.
I guess a big pineapple.
She's five pounds, right now,
with six weeks to go.
So, this is how it looks right now.
Tomorrow they're bringing
the bed and the chair.
We are missing the shelves,
but Stew is being nosy already.
Well, she's going to be an amazing mom.
We've got two amazing moms
we're going to have here.
So this is...
It's-
Hold it together.
I know.
Even like with her,
with her dog, you know,
so she's very protective of the dog.
She's gonna be a pretty
emotional mom, I think.
What I realized was, what
do you want for your kids?
You know, you want them
to be happy, that's it.
You just want them to be happy.
And she's happy.
And my mom says all the time, like,
I've never seen you so
happy, and feeling so free.
Even the last time we
were together at home,
she was like, "You're more
nicer when she's around."
She said, and her mom sends
random voice notes on WhatsApp,
like just crying, she's crying,
and I don't know what she's saying,
but I'm like, "what is she saying?"
and she's like, "She's just
so happy that we're happy."
How, when, if, are you
gonna tell your child
about how she was brought into this world?
And I think for us is
we're just gonna continue to be honest,
be genuine, be authentic.
I think the same way that we are
in our lives, with the rest of the world,
like that's how we're gonna be with Ruby.
She deserves to know the entire process.
I think we're ready.
Yeah.
And if not, we go shopping.
I can't believe this
is actually happening.
I'm still in shock.
This is our last night
together before I go to Tokyo.
We have only 28 days left until she comes.
We have 45 minutes left together,
because she has another thing to do.
And also being the two of us
until the little one comes.
Yep.
It's about to be three.
With a gold medal.
Yes.
Being in Tokyo with the gold medal
being put around my neck,
it's just even more worth it.
I've always been on big stages,
but now it's more than
me, and more than us.
But for this little one to kinda
see what she can do.
I can't believe it's actually,
the day is actually here.
It's happening.
I just got back from Tokyo yesterday,
landed in LA, flew to Idaho,
and now we're here.
What is jet lag?
What even is jet lag?
I don't know.
I had this idea where I was like,
her middle name should be Tokyo.
First of all, we don't
have middle names in Spain,
so it's like, that's another
thing that I was like,
"Okay, just something easy.
I'm not going to call her Ruby Tokyo."
That, I'm like, "That
doesn't go together."
And then with all these surnames,
because we need to figure
out about the surnames.
It's like, okay, just choose another one.
So now the next dog will be Tokyo.
Because she wants a puppy, you know?
Stew needs a friend.
He's gonna have Ruby.
So-
I'm like,
I don't know whose life
is going to change more
his or ours.